Jenny McCarthy shares her favorite
memory of the late Hugh Hefner I'm very
honest very raw very real everything I
wanted from Playboy has gotten the
Sirius XM hosts who rose to fame after
being named Playmate of the Year in the
early 90s is opening up about the
playboy icon who died at the age of 91
last month
Jenny reminisced about a priceless
memory she had with Hefner at her first
Playboy audition on Sundays watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen when I was
trying out to be centerfold they
actually give the girls five days of a
test so you shoot one position for five
days and on the floor was the position
it was I can imitate it eight hours a
day for five days and on day four the
producer or production whatever editor
said come meet with me half is on the
phone and have said you've got one more
chance go home and practice because your
face it looks like you just hit a deer
with your car
you look so horrified so I went home
that night and kept going like trying to
find sexy and I came back and go listen
all you're gonna get is a smile that's
all I know how to do so my centerfold
was me going and they they got God
normal it's just too boring for me
[Music]